good morning good afternoon and good
evening my name is chung zhang and i'm a
machine learning researcher from
microsoft research cambridge uk on
behalf of all our organizers including
emily kissman amit sharma greg lewis and
vasilis saganis we welcome all of you to
the causal machine learning track the
microsoft research submit
machine learning based on correlation
have achieved massive success in many
real-world applications for prediction
tasks
for example image classification
however as we aim for more real world
impact in the field we recognize that
current methods are inefficient
so we need to understand the causal
relationship to make interventional
decisions in areas such as healthcare or
finance
current machine learning methods also
suffers from generalization robustness
and fairness issues we believe that
causality can help overcome these issues
to enable even greater social impacts
from machine learning while causality is
seeing increasing attention in the
machine learning community collate
itself actually has a long history as a
research topic it has been developed in
various domains such as economics
statistics and computer science and
that's why we invited speakers and
panelists with different customer
machine learning backgrounds both within
and beyond microsoft research to share
their latest research and their vision
for the future within microsoft we
advance causal machine learning research
in theory and develop frameworks such as
do y equal ml and azure to enable more
people to build on our work
we have applied causal machine learning
across domains such as in privacy and
gaming
you will hear about this work throughout
today's sessions in addition we have
invited top researchers from
universities and industrial research
labs to share their thoughts with you
today as well
you will learn about our vision in our
opening talk followed by a couple of
short lightening talks and i'm really
really looking forward to today's panel
discussion moderated by our chief
science advisor eric howitz
and with panelists including professor
joshua bingell professor susan acy and
professor julia pearl
this esteemed group will discuss their
view of the challenges and opportunities
in causal machine learning
we will also have multiple presentations
from additional industrial labs and
universities our speakers including
robert west and nathan carlos
in the second part of the session we'll
focus more on the impact of causal
machine learning
you will see demos from dubai and our
economy group followed by two really
exciting panel discussions regarding
cultural machine learning in practice at
microsoft and in industry in general we
have invited panelists from
netflix toyota and linkedin to share
their thoughts
thank you for joining us we are very
excited about the research in this field
and we know you will be too